peut-être la secte est bon parce qu' il
fallait d'abord vie que suit à l'olympia
tout le temps donc je suis très fatigué
il faut que je fasse un peu de sport on
m'a dit que si je faisais un peu de vélo
pour m'aérer les autres adaptations
voire même un peu de football - devrait
aider à ma condition physique
j'ai tout compris au foot j'ai tout
compris
c'est con mais déjà si tu as compris le
mot football tu as tout compris le sport
dans le mot football ya bolt qui veut
dire ballot qui veut dire que c'est un
jeu qui se joue avec un ballon et puis
le mettre en face qui garde les buts le
ballon fuit foot
ce qui n'a rien à voir avec le baseball
oui c'est un précédent une équipe il ya
11 joueurs nous on avait 11 caractères
différents
on en avait un il était là genre de mec
un peu timide voyez alors ils étaient là
comme ça et faites-moi passe à l'essai
suis démarqué à l'est mais soyez cool
faites-moi passe une fois quoi ça fait
quatorze mois giuseppe n'a pas touché le
ballon je fais rien
s'il fallait droit manière
on en avait un autre il était timide
mais en plus ils étaient bonnes et puis
il était myope ans était pire que tout
le projet il était la banda you may
berenbaum vélos vélos vélos et les
vannes aux bailleurs à l'ena milla avait
fait repasse m'avait faire passe au
cordeau robert avec j'avais pas vu tu
étais tombé par terre
d'ailleurs beaubois la tête là robert
keller le blessé on se demande si c'est
du vrai vous du chiqué il ya toujours un
blessé vous savez web et aaa à nancy
facile fait le cadre de nos capacités
passif à la photokina vas-y attaque
attaquerait pastebin fumier touche le
montois web à 10 1 c'est la mi temps au
vestiaire à dans une équipe de foot
humain qui est très important c'est le
remplaçant le remplaçant il remplace
alors avant de remplacer il s'échauffe
des fois il s'échauffe tout le maintien
par rapport à toute attente attente en
titane ou encore tu viendras sans talon
pointe au talon pointe à 1 à moi de
jouer là non je population à y en a un
qui est super je sais pas si vous avez
fait gaffe mais en ce moment dans
l'équipe du cameroun ya un noir j'ai dit
une connerie là il ya un noir foncé
chaque fois qu'il fait une belle action
il en parle avec le poteau du corner
l'industrie alors ça fait comme ça tu
sais tout obama et ma main ou mais le
poteau ils sont fous l'europe où ils
bougent pas ça et puis alors ya le but
le but c'est important le mec qui marque
un but
ouais ouais ouais ouais c'est rémi gellé
mais ouais de tests briques pas moi je
passe à 30 briques par mois ouais je
monte de division
ouais de foot des bio ouais et puis ça
doit être ça doit être un petit peu
sexuelle le foot à mon avis parce que je
sais pas si vous avez vu
mais l'esprit d'équipé caen l1 qui
marque un but c'est impressionnant alors
le mec il marque le but tu as well et
messieurs les viviers embrasse moi ouais
ouais moi aussi j embrasse moi well i do
i do ou alouettes je les missiles
ennemis
huawei je l'aimé quand le coup franc
voilà un moment qu'il est grand le coup
franc alors tu as le goal il fait le mur
asie sers toi
ouais ouais sers-toi plus masi le goalie
s'en fout il est derrière mais le mec
devant
il tenait un autre à côté
hilton à un troisième et un quatrième si
bas alors qui c'est qui le met deux
coups francs
challandes est comme ça il y en a dans
chaque équipe
généralement ils viennent du brésil cela
ah ouais alors ça fait comme ça t'es
acheté slicks alors le mec qui arrive
avec essais m'ont fait ses profits elles
ont commencé le match sur moi ah ben non
c'est pas ma faute c'est l'autre mais tu
as m avait caché mon short alors
vraiment bon en est à combien catadores
vont nous mondiale à branler qu'on leur
met alors aujourd'hui je fais la
diversion je suis responsable de la
diversion on m'appelait la diverses ça
se passe en deux temps premier temps qui
changent des tétines des chaussures pour
m'aider beaucoup plus longue
deuxième temps tu excite le capitaine de
l'équipe adverse de profits qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait tout excité m court
derrière quand je la sens bien proche de
moi je m'arrête net lui ben moi je serre
les pelles ces gens mais l'enjeu oui je
sais ça m'a choqué plusieurs mais ça
m'est égal mois passés de toute façon
même si football in vire je rentre chez
moi il n'y a pas que le foot dans la vie
y'a la samba
c'est bien ça va se faire la guerre